[Music]
okay everybody this is my spoiler free
review of the rehearsal this comes from
the brilliant nathan fielder who also
did nathan for you i was really excited
about this because it is now hbo so he
has more leeway he doesn't worry about
commercial breaks or censoring like what
happened on comedy central so this show
they sent us the first five we haven't
got anything beyond that and it's
interesting because
i had a lot of feelings about the show
like i did about nathan for you where
it's brilliant in so many parts nathan
fields is a different level of comedy
and he really is like the king of dry
humor and he never breaks character and
he just keeps pushing the limits to what
you can do and that's really where the
core of his humor shines again where he
just gets more ridiculous and ridiculous
but where it also shines is he's always
good at bringing heart to it and making
you think about people that are alone
and deeper messages and themes and
there's a lot of like seriousness to
this show even more than nathan for you
and what you'll see is even episode one
it's showing you that episode one to me
was the most serious and i was more
emotional than even laughing in that
episode so it shows a growth on nathan
fielder's part and what he can do and
what continues with nathan fielder is in
any genre no one puts more effort into
their work than nathan fielder that's
why it takes so long for it to come out
you know he's kind of planning and
plotting these different things and as
you watch it you're just like how did he
think of that or how did he pull this
off he's just constantly putting that
super effort into everything he does and
you'll see the standouts for me is the
premiere and to me episode three is an
absolute masterpiece because it's where
he hits that brilliance where he did hit
and a lot of nathan few episodes where
it's like the perfect mix of great humor
but also great themes that hit your soul
it's like a nice tonal mash there and it
really highlights themes about ignorance
and your connection to nathan can be
unreal at points he really hits that
like he really gets you into his mind
now the only thing i'll say is that like
kind of what happens in anything for you
in some episodes i would say episode
four and five it loses steam a bit and
that there's a concept here i'm not
going to spoil it maybe gets a little
stretched out there is a plot line that
goes on throughout the season where the
whole concept of the show is great but
you almost wish it expanded to more
locations and things and it kind of kind
of starts to play out by the end here
and i also feel like that's a result of
kovid this is probably the most coveted
affected show i've seen yet where you're
like oh my god like if maybe cover was
in the way that would have been more of
a case for them to expand locations and
stuff like that more ideas they could
have done so i do feel like it was
limited and i feel like it just needs a
little more consistency and actually
wanted more laughs here believe it or
not i think that
it starts to almost get in its way of
being a little too serious and redundant
towards the end that's the only
criticism i will say of this show but
again it really is
amazing and if you like neither of you
you're gonna like this i think it's
definitely
8.8 i'm gonna give it and probably the
same level nathan for you i think there
is wanting maybe more i don't think it
maybe totally went to the next level i
think it's really just as good as nathan
for you and people who love nathan
fielder are gonna love this if you have
anything for you you're gonna love this
but again i feel like there's potential
for to be absolute masterpiece close not
totally though again because limitations
it feels like because of covid and
sometimes maybe almost getting in its
own way being a little too serious or
too redundant towards the end but
otherwise definitely worth a watch and
i'm excited for everyone to see this and
talk about it it's gonna get a lot of
buzz because it's some crazy stuff and
i'm not gonna spoil any of that of
course because you have to enjoy that
magic on first watch without knowing
anything going in i wouldn't even watch
a trailer just go in cold and really
just take it in and you know just be
happy we have someone who's still doing
great comedy like nathan fielder so let
me know if you plan to watch i'd love to
hear your comments about it anything
what you thought nathan for you as well
what do you think nathan fielders work
as a whole i'd love to hear that if you
plan on watching this and let me know
when you do watch what you thought i'd
love to hear that as well please follow
me at steve barley show on twitter
instagram and tick tock for more of me
and i'll see you next time